[Musique]
bonsoir nous sommes le jeudi 21 janvier
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 78 le journal comme
chaque jour vous le savez votre
information locale accompagnée de nos
invités mais également des journalistes
de la rédaction tout de suite les titres
de cette
édition sa première vidéo a fait plus de
10000 vues sur Internet vocation 78
c'est le nom de cette chaîne Youtube
dont l'objectif est de susciter les
vocations religieuses chez les jeunes
pour nous en parler le Père Mathieu de
Raymont curry du chaîné et de
rquencour le FC moi 78 ses vu l'émininé
hier de la Coupe de France par le club
Ligue 1 le FC Nantes défaite 1-0 pour
les amateurs qui s'arrêtent en 16e de
finale à domicile à
montlaville et à l'occasion de la
Journée internationale du sport féminin
portrait de Béatrice Mendy boxeuse de la
team farouia de Saint-Quentin en Yveline
ce sera le thème de votre chronique
sport du jeudi avec Michael midoro et un
nouveau pic de pollution au particules
fines a eu lieu en Île-de-France ce
jeudi la préfecture de police de Paris a
recommandé aux Franciliens de prendre
des mesures afin de ne pas augmenter
davantage encore l'émission de polluant
on écoute tout de suite Charlotte
songeur elle est ingénieur
prévisionniste pour airpif elle nous
explique les raisons de cette pollution
ainsi que les gestes à
observer depuis mercredi on a des
des des émissions importantes que ça
soit du aux conditions hivernales donc
le chauffage mais aussi de trafic qui
qui émettent donc beaucoup de particules
et des conditions météorologiques qui
vont empêcher la dispersion de ces
particules c'est pour ça que depuis 2
jours en fait on a des concentrations en
partic qui sont élevé les consignes pour
des épisodes de pollution hivernale ça
va être éviter les les heur de pointe
pour les automobilistes les piétons les
les
cyclistes et ça va être aéré son
liitation pour aussi évacuer la
pollution qui peut qui peut stagner à
l'intérieur des bâtiments les
Franciliens était ainsi encouragé à
emprunter les transports en commun à
privilégier le covoiturage et à réduire
leur vitesse sur l'ensemble de la région
des renforcements des contrôles de
vitesse et des contrôles antipollution
des véhicules ont également eu lieu ce
jeudi mais rassurez-vous les conditions
météorologiques des jours à venir vont
permettre de disperser cette pollution
et le recensement a commencé aujourd'hui
et s'achèvera le 20 février prochain si
vous êtes concerné cette année vous
pouvez désormais remplir vos
informations en ligne pour ceux qui
n'ont pas de connexion Internet le
formulaire papier existe toujours mais à
quoi servent les chiffres collectés et
comment se déroule une campagne de
recensement élément de réponse avec
Fanny Bourdillon donc je me présente
Madame Fedrigo agent recenseur pour la
commune de manie d'accord donc je viens
donc pour le recensement et donc je vous
nouveauté cette année dans plusieurs
communes dont Manil amo le recensement
pourra se faire sur Internet un
formulaire à remplir en ligne qui
simplifie le travail des agents
recenseurs mais aussi des habitants nous
préférons que les personnes répondent
par Internet puisque il y a un gain de
temps puisqu'on repasse pas une deuxième
fois et puis en plus un gain de de
papier et un gain de temps aussi pour
les personn puisqueil y a un filtre sur
internet donc ça évite de remplir tout
le questionnaire notamment comme là on a
une personne qui est toute seule donc ça
va plus vite à remplir sur Internet
puisqueil y a un filtre donc il y aura
moins de questions par internet je vais
voir mais effectivement si en plus quand
j'emp une case on m fait pas remplir
enfin j'ai pas en lire trois en dessous
parce que je suis pas concerné ça va
quand même être plus rapide et plus
efficace pour tout le monde et donc
cette année il y a la nouveauté sur
Internet al je sais pas si ça vous
intéresse sur Internet ou vous voulez le
la formule papier non je préfère papier
moi je suis pas je de la V àécole parce
que PAP sur papier ou sur internet le
recensement est obligatoire et ces
données sont très précieuses pour les
communes ça sert par exemple à prendre
des décisions au niveau de la commune en
matière d'équipement collectif pour
construire une crèche ouvrir des classes
dans des écoles en matière de transport
voilà donc ça c'est des choses très très
concrètes ça sert à votre commune à bien
connaître sa population et donc à
prendre les bonnes décisions pour la
collectivité 17 agents recenseront la
ville de manilé àau cette année en
moyenne un logement est sondé tous les 5
ans prénon une chaîne Youtube qui parle
de la vocation religieuse et qui fait
des émules sur internet ce n'est pas
banal et c'est le thème de notre
entretien d'aujourd'hui pour nous en
parler en plateau le Père Mathieu de
Raymon curé à la paroisse du ch de
reconcours bonsoir et merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation alors vous êtes
un peu le youtubeur le youtubeur qui
fait vivre cette chaîne c'est ça le
prêtre youtubeur alors elle a cette
vidéo don dont je vous parle il y a une
vidéo un teaser elle a été mise en ligne
le 10 janvier mais juste donc c'était
une vidéo pour annoncer le lancement de
la chaîne et elle a fait plus de 10000
vues je vous propose d'en regarder un
[Musique]
extrait
il se passe quoi on veut le lien on veut
tous le lien mais non mais ce n'est pas
prêt ça ouvre le 10 janvier à
midi alors c'était la vidéo teaser pour
annoncer lancement de la chaîne vocation
78 c'est une vidéo pe décaler comment
vous est venu l'idée de faire ça alors
cette idée là vient des jeunes eux-mêmes
qui m'ont dit voilà vous pouvez pas
lancer une une chaîne YouTube sur les
vocations vocations 78 donc sans qu'il y
ait un teaser c'est c'est ce qu'il faut
alors voilà moi je connaissais à peine
le mot teaser et donc on a mis en scène
cette ce schéma où où en fait plusieurs
jeunes quittent une situation de vie
cour au presbytère donc vous l'avez vu
le QG d'évocation et demande absolument
le lien pour avoir des témoignages le
but de la chaîne c'est de montrer que
les prêes les religieux religieus
aujourd'hui sont pas des zombies mais
ont une vie normale sont capables de
répondre à des questions avec cœur de
manière authentique et donc d'avoir des
témoignages qui donnent vie justement à
la vocation alors voilà la la vidéo a
fait plus de 10000 vues je le disais
vous attendiez un tel engouement à
autant de retours voilà je dois vous
avouer que je ne m'attendais pas à un
tel engouement effectivement il y a eu
des partages étonnants improbables des
différents sites qui ont publier notre
teaser et ensuite la chaîne et et
jusqu'en Espagne il y a une chaîne
espagnole catholique hein qui a publié
voilà que se passe-t-il donc en France
et ils mettent justement le le teaser en
le traduisant en dessous alors cette
chaîne Youtube elle est sur ce ce média
c'est une initiative du diocèse des
Yvelines ça ne se fait pas partout en
France non voilà c'est initiative du
diocèse de Versailles mon évêque m' nomé
récemment délégué au vocation et m'a
demandé de donner une visibilité
justement à au à ceux et celles qui
s'engage à l'appel de Dieu c'est ça une
vocation hein c'est recevoir l'appel de
Dieu pour consacrer sa vie euh à
l'Évangile au message de la foi donc
l'objectif c'était un petit peu de
donner un coup de jeûne à la religion
justement thème de la vocation via les
nouveaux médias et les réseaux sociaux
si vous voulez on peut le voir comme ça
ouais est-ce que justement il y a
d'autres paramètres que vous prenez en
compte par exemple sur Twitter ou ou je
sais pas Facebook également al pour le
moment page facebook vocation 78 et
chaîne Youtube effectivement si on nous
le demande on ira plus loin mais là je
pense que le le but c'est surtout
d'avoir de l'image donc c'est pas tant
des Tet voyez que des des vidéos qui du
une minute 30 le format est fait
justement pour ne pas lasser un jeunne
entre 16 et 22 25 ans c'est ça la cible
d'accord alors ça c'est c'était la vidéo
teaser donc que nous avons vu on trouve
surtout sur cette chaîne Youtube des
témoignages pour expliquer l'engagement
dans la religion aux jeunes regardant un
extrait le célibat du prêtre pour moi il
a trois sens le premier c'est d'être le
signe d'une consécration totale à Dieu
notre vie est totalement donnée à Dieu
prêtre c'est pas un métier c'est c'est
le don total de sa vie Dieu peut combler
une vie et notre bonheur en témoignant
donc ce sont des témoignages comme
celui-ci sur différentes questions que
l'on peut retrouver sur la chaîne
Youtube voilà on a plus de 50
témoignages on en est à 51 52 je crois
et je vais en rajouter un à peu près
toutes les semaines tous les 15 jours et
le but c'est d'avoir différents visages
donc il y a pas trois prêtres ou trois
religieuses qui fonctionnent voyez on a
vraiment au moins 45 visages différents
qui répondent à une question directe et
sans faire de détours alors comment ça
se passe estce que c'est c'est vous qui
filmez comment vous choisissez les
thèmes abordés alors les thèmes abordés
sont choisis en fonction de celui qui
parle c'est-à-dire que je choisis le
prêtre ou la religieuse que je pense
voilà pouvoir faire l'exercice parce que
parler en une minute 30 c'est pas facile
d'un quel que soit le sujet et ensuite
je demande à chacun voilà quel est le
sujet sur lequel tu pourrais nous
apporter quelque chose donc ça
correspond un peu au charisme de ceux
qui parlent et le défi voilà c'est de
réussir à témoigner authentiquement de
ce que l'on vit sans faire encore une
fois de de sans faire rêver vous verrez
qu'il y a des témoignages aussi ou des
religieuses nous nous disent la
difficulté de la fidélité par exemple
donc le but c'est pas de faire rêver
c'est de montrer du réel c'est vous vous
déplacez vous-même vous filmez avec
votre téléphone avec une caméra je me
déplace moi-même il se trouve que dans
notre métier on est souvent ensemble je
je sors là tout juste d'une réunion de
prêtre autour de notre évêque et j'ai
filmé un jeune prêtre par exemple qui
intervient à la radio sur Radio
Notre-Dame et il m'en parle pendant une
minute 30 je vais monter ça ce soir ou
demain et ça fera une vidéo disponible
comment l'initiative a-t-elle été
accueillie et par les jeunes est-ce que
vous avez déjà des retours et également
aussi par les personnes que vous
interviewez écoutez par les personnes
que j'ai
interviewé la l'initiative est
accueillie avec joie parce que déjà je
les prends pas au dépourvu je leur pose
une question il est vrai souvent au
dernier moment c'est peu préparé de
manière à ce que ça reste authentique et
et et direct il y a rien de vraiment
monté euh ensuite je filme avec mon
iPhone tout simplement j'allais dire
donc c'est une qualité comment on dit
amateur mais qui a un petit petit côté
professionnel vous vous verrez et
ensuite je crois que l'adhésion du
public est réelle on le voit au nombre
de vues tout simplement on en est à peu
près à 60000 vues pour une cinquantaine
de vidéos la plus vue étant à 4800 je
crois actuellement la moins vue étant à
250 en tout ça en 10 jours donc
l'adhésion voilà est réelle donc c'est
un bon démarrage est-ce que vous avez
déjà eu des retour des jeunes qui
auraient peut-être visionné ces vidéos
qui se sera dit B voilà j'ai moi aussi
la vocation alors on a des retours
d'abord de jeunes qui nous disent je me
prends au jeu et j'ai vu les 50 par
exemple bon c'est un peu l'addiction à
Internet qui m'interpelle aussi hein
mais bon il faut qu'on se situe aussi
dans dans ce média un retour le le plus
beau retour que j'ai eu c'est un prêtre
qui me dit qu'un jeune est venu lui
parler dans son lycée je crois en lui
disant voilà j'ai vu plusieurs vidéos et
là je me lance je viens vous parler de
ce qui peut-être est ma vocation
parlons-en quoi c'est difficile de
parler de la vocation aux jeunes parce
que c'est vrai vrai que c'est un thème
qui est quand même difficile même pour
les jeunes chrétiens il ne s'imaginent
pas spécialement rentrer dans les
orortes si on peut dire alors
détrompez-vous il y un sondage a été
réalisé pour la croix le journal La
Croix il y a il y a un mois ou deux et
on en a parlé pas mal un Français sur 10
attendez 2 secondes zut je suis
incapable de vous donner les chiffres il
y a beaucoup plus de Français je crois
que c'est un/ 10 voir 2/ 10 qui a pensé
à la vocation religieuse un Français he
sur 10 ce qui veut dire que l'idée de
consacrer sa vie l'idée de quitter alors
il faut pas que ce soit une fuite mais
l'idée de quitter le monde pour ainsi
dire pour donner sa vie à un idéal fort
et à Dieu en l'occurrence pour un
chrétien et bien n'est pas si absente
qu'on l'imagine du paysage par contre
après il y a des exigences et la
question va être le discernement va se
faire à ce niveau-là suis-je
véritablement appelé et donc capable
d'entrer dans les exigences propres à la
vocation religieuse avec le célibat par
exemple ou la pauvreté voilà il y a des
questions fortes je crois que les jeunes
d'aujourd'hui sont beaucoup plus
désireux de vivre un idéal qu'on
l'imagine est-ce que justement vous
prévenez ces jeunes qui souhaitent
peut-être voilà qui ont une vocation qui
viennent vers vous pour rentrer dans les
ordres vous le dites voilà il faut faire
attention ce n'est pas si facile c'est
une voie difficile vous les mettez en
garde il y a un processus de recrutement
si l'on peut dire ainsi alors en
regardant les vidéos vous verrez qu'il
n'y a aucune démagogie enfin je l'espère
tout du moins et qu' que l'on montre
aussi les difficultés euh difficultés et
puis appel à la sainteté ça veut dire
exigence c'est pas seulement difficile
c'est exigeant mais cette exigence voilà
elle est désirée par beaucoup il ne faut
pas que ça soit je viens de le dire une
fuite du monde il ne faut pas non plus
que ça soit la volonté de de monter une
montagne pour être vainqueur au sommet
il faut que l'appel de Dieu soit présent
et c'est ça que nous allons discerner
d'abord dans un accompagnement spirituel
des jeunes avant d'entrer au séminaire
on demande à un jeunne d'avoir un
accompagnateur spirituelle ou une
religieuse une accompagnatrice et enfin
lorsqu'un jeunne est présenté pour
l'entrée au séminaire il y a un dossier
qui est fait et on lui demande je crois
une dizaine de témoignages de de de
laïqu de prêtres de religieux qui
l'entoure et qui
témoigne de la de la qualité de sa vie
et de son appel voilà on fait attention
justement voilà c'est une dernière
question av nous quitter c'est c'est une
initiative qui est dans les Yvelines
est-ce qu'il y a peut-être un manque de
séminaristes dans les ivelines alors on
peut pas dire que dans les ivelines on
manque de séminarises puisqu'on est l'un
des diocèses qui en a le plus on a une
quarantaine de séinariste en gros en
formation pour devenir prêtre euh par
contre on peut dire que à l'échelle de
la France effectivement il y a un manque
qui se fait maintenant criant de de
vocation sacerdotal et religieuse les
religieuses aussi vont commencer à
s'effacer petit à petit du territoire
français et cela peut nous inquiéter et
en même temps euh cela correspond au au
nombre euh de de de croyants pratiquants
dans nos campagnes ou dans dans notre
pays donc le le le ratio voyez entre les
deux est quasiment toujours le même mais
dans une société où l'idéal est de moins
en moins présent et la consommation
peut-être de plus en plus dictatoriale
voilà comme idéal de vie et bien il est
important voilà de de de montrer que
beaucoup de jeunes encore aujourd'hui
sont capables de suivre cette voie
exigeante de la consération totale merci
beaucoup Père Mathieu de Raymond alors
vous pouvez retrouver toutes les
informations sur la chaîne Youtube
vocation 78 ainsi que sur votre page
Facebook qui s'appelle également
vocation
78 tout autre sujet à présent les
Compagnons du Devoir représentent une
certaine forme de l'élite de l'artisanat
à l'occasion des journées portes
ouvertes chez les Compagnons du Devoir
ce weekend nous vous proposons un
portrait celui de Louis Charles SPEN il
est SPEN pardon il est apprenti
compagnon carrossier et il réside dans
la maison d'épôes dans les ivelines
regardez ce portrait signé Sephora
Namani et William L
comme je t'exliqua tout à
l'heurere toujours du côté gauche
Compagnon du Devoir si filières 29
métiers Louis char 17 ans est en 2e
année d'apprentissage en carrosserie une
envie suscitée par son père compagnon
tapissier depuis ce matin on a commencé
à fixer le plateau au plancher et on
vient d'installer le cadre en fait on
travaille au millimè c'est ça qui c'est
il faut que que tout soit
carré parce que sinon au bout d'un
moment ça va pas
quoi mets ton pied en dessous pour la
caler et là on
baisse et voilà et on est passé Louis
Charles est inscrit auprès du centre de
formation en alternance de tour afin de
décrocher son bac professionnel le
rythme est soutenu avec 6 semaines en
entreprise et de semaines en école un
système plaisant pour les apprentis
compagnons qui bénéficient d'une
rémunération ATT active et pour les
entreprises qui apprécient le sérieux de
ses apprentis compagnons on va dire
qu'ils sont plus motivés par le fait
d'apprendre un métier fin de la journée
en entreprise à 16h30 après 7 he de
travail physique et minutieux et voilà
16h55
fini un coup de B la suite du programme
après ça et ben on rentre à la maison
j'espère que je vais pouvoir prendre ma
douche s'il y a encore de l'eau chaude
et après à
manger voilà bienvenu dans mon humble
demeure Louis Charles a choisi de
résider dans la maison des Compagnons
pendant son apprentissage une maison
située à épone dans les Yvelines au sein
d'un vieux moulin il pie 600 € par mois
pour le git et le couvert il y en a
beaucoup qui n'aiment pas ils trouvent
que c'est mieux de voir leur potes le
soir enfin moi aussi j'aimerais bien
mais voilà je suis un peu loin de chez
moi on peut parler de de tout la journée
qui qui vient de se dérouler de ça
permet quoi en
fait de savoir que les autres ont passé
une journée pire que laenne ici chacun a
un rôle bien défini vaisselle cuisine
ménage ou organisateur de loisir comme
Louis Charles une vie en communauté
organisée par des règles vieilles de 800
ans c'est très important parce que
autrement les jeunes vont apprendre
simplement une formation et nous c'est
c'est pas ça l'idée c'est vraiment
d'apprendre un métier mais tout ça en
communauté parce que le partage le vivre
ensemble nous c'est des éléments très
importants et donc ce qui fait que ça ça
permet aux jeunes de se perfectionner et
et de surtout de créer une certaine
autonomie déjà très jeune à l'issue de
son apprentissage il rêve d'intégrer les
5 ans de formation du Tour de France
pour être adoubé compagnon du devoir à
chaque année il découvrira une ville et
une entreprise différente parfois même à
l'étranger le métier est changeant selon
la région où se trouve ça permet aux
jeunes de s'adapter bien sûr leur milieu
d'entreprise dans la région et après
aussi de entreprise grâce à la base de
la formation dans le cadre de son
apprentissage Vaah apprendre d'autres
technicités d'autres spécialités de son
métier et automatiquement dévolu plus
rapidement en attendant direction les
cours du soir 2 heur de français math
anglais ou dessin technique la formation
est exigeante mais elle garantit aux
Compagnons du Devoir de trouver un
emploi et je le rappelle les journées
portes ouvertes pour découvrir le métier
de compagnon du du devoir se déroule ce
weekend dans les différentes maisons
dans les élines rendez-vous du 22 au 24
janvier à la maison des paôes et on
passe au sport à présent fin de de
l'aventure en Coupe de France pour le FC
Manois 78 les hommes de Robert Mendy se
sont inclinés en prolongation contre
l'équipe du FC Nantes à domicile il n'y
a donc plus d'équipe ivlinoise en Coupe
de France retour sur l'aventure avec
Michel midoro et Patrick Jacques de
dixmud fin de l'aventure du FC Montois
78 en Coupe de France les 100or
Yvelinois qui évoluent en CFA se sont
inclinés ce mercredi en 16e de finale au
stade Aimé bergal après prolongation 1-0
contre le club de Ligue 1 du FC Nantes
déçu vraiment déçu comme je disais
précédemment c'est qu'on attendait
vraiment les tirs au but on avait réussi
à les ammener en prolongation le but il
était l'objectif il était atteint après
ça j'ai joué à soir quoi 5 10 minutes
donc voilà une erreur d'inattention
contre les les Ligue 1 ça paye cche et
ce soir on a été plutôt pas mal
défensivement après comme je disais je
regrette qu'il a manqué un peu de folie
ils avons un super état d'esprit ils ont
ils ont donné leur maximum puis voilà on
a à un certain moment juste à la fin on
a été on a eu un petit peu de chance
parce que je pense qu'il pouvait nous
égaliser mais bon sur le sur la vue du
match c'était mérité mais absolument pas
surpris par par eux au contraire malgré
la défaites et les températures
glaciales les 5500 supporters présents
au stade avaient le sourire à la fin de
la rencontre
on méritait je pense qu'on méritait de
gagner il y a eu de la combativité c'est
la magie de la Coupe de France ok c'est
pas grave on est là encore FC mon FC mon
vous inquiétez pas l'année prochaine on
va gagner la coupe vous inquiétez pas on
est on est tous ensemble au star de
France vous inquiétez pas monsieur le FC
Montois devra se replonger dans le
quotidien du championnat dès ce weekend
les manés affronteront aubertvilliers ce
samedi à 18h et nous recevons à présent
sur ce plateau notre journaliste sportif
Michel elmidoro pour une chronique sport
un peu particulière bonsoir Michel
bonsoir Flor à l'occasion de la Journée
internationale du sport féminin qui sera
programmée ce samedi 24 janvier je vous
propose un portrait je vais vous parler
d'une jeune athlète de 16 ans batrice
Mendy C étudiante a intégré en 2012 la
team farouia à hencour l'une des
meilleures équipes françaises de boxe
qui a notamment propulsé sur le devant
de la scène des boxeurs comme le
champion d'Europe Adila Madi ou encore
le champion de France Marvin petit
l'adolescente nous explique son choix il
y avait une amie à moi qui faisait de la
boxe ici elle m'a dit que que la boxe lu
apport beaucoup de Ch ch et tout ce soit
le mental et elle aimait beaucoup ça
donc je me suis dit pourquoi pas me
lancer je suis allé la boxe est encore
un sport peu féminisé en France sur les
45000 boxeurs licenciés seulement 15 %
sont des femmes Béatrice Mendi doit par
exemple combattre à l'entraînement avec
des garçons comme nous l'a expliqué ce
qui n'a pas été facile à faire accepter
à part sa famille au départ ma mère elle
voulait pas du tout mais après avec les
frères et sœurs parce que j'ai surtout
vécu avec des garçons j'ai quatre frères
et voilà après c'est toujours eux qu'ils
étaient derrière moi pour pour me dire
continuer et tout mes amis après ils
m'ont dit ouais pourquoi tu vas faire de
la boxe alors que tu es une fille je me
suis dit bah non sans sport comme les
autres je peux faire aussi moi je dit
que on peut faire comme les garçons
aussi tout le monde est égau et du coup
si les garçons il les font pourquoi nous
on ferait pas ça devient de plus en plus
courant il y a des championnes des
championns du monde français plus il y a
pas d'hommes champion du monde mais il y
a des femmes qui sont champion du monde
actuellement depuis ses premiers pas
dans la boxe Beatrice Mendy fait la loi
sur le R elle a notamment été championne
de France et championne régionale en
2015 et elle veut continuer j'aimerais
bien bien rentrer dans l'équipe des Jeux
Olympiques je l'équipe de France la
jeune batrice Mendy n'a pas encore de
combat programmés dans les prochaines
semaines on vous tiendra évidemment
informé de son actualité dans les
prochaines émissions sport de TVfil 78
bien merci Michel ça donne envie de se
mettre à la box après ce portrait on
passe au rendez-vous sportif du weekend
par ce temps glacial on va jouer sur les
terrains football en promotion d'honneur
trap qui a été pendant de longues
semaines leader du classement de la pouc
se déplacera sur le terrain de Clichy
sursène les traapistes seront favoris de
cette rencontre ils occupent
actuellement la 3e place avec un bilan
de 6 victoires de nuls et trois défaites
alors que son adversaire Clichy pointe à
la 8e place mais on ne peut jamais
prévoir le résultat d'un match d'autant
plus que les surfaces de jeu
ressembleront plus à des patin noir qu'à
les terrains de football et on
recommande à notreapiste d'emporter dans
leur sac les bons crampons on joua
également en fédéral 3 de rugby
Versailles recevra la CBB c'est le match
à ne pas perdre pour le Rugby Club de
Versailles les joueurs de la cité royale
bon dernier du classement avec seulement
huit petits points engrangés depuis le
début de la saison reçoiv le 6e Boulogne
bien en cours à la maison la défaite est
interdite en cas de contreperformance
les Versaillais pourront déjà faire une
croix sur le maintien pour les soutenir
le match est programmé ce dimanche à 15h
au stade de porsche-fontaine Floran
merci Michel on leur souhaite bien sûr
de se maintenir on vous retrouve dans
quelques instants pour votre Tol que si
on parle sport allez Michel faites-moi
un petit teasing évidemment Floran je ne
peux rien vous refuser on parlera
notamment du coup de la défaite en Coupe
de France de Manes contre Nant mais
également du PISTAR inimontin François
Pervis qui ira au GI 2016 à Rio et bien
j'ai hâte de voir ça le programme est
exqui n'oubliez pas l'horaire c'est
19h30 et avant de nous quitter cette
cette dernière information les bénévoles
des 23 structures du Secours populaire
euh français des ziviles se sont
rassemblés hier pour une galette des
rois un événement organisé dans le cadre
du don action la campagne permet à
l'association de collecter les
ressources nécessaires à son
fonctionnement un moyen pour les
nouveaux bénévoles de rencontrer ceux
qui agissent depuis plus longtemps sur
le terrain ils ont également tenu leur
comité départemental pour parler de
l'année 2016 les précisions au micro de
William
l là c'est la feuille de route de la
direction départementale pour les deux
prochaines années donc nécessairement ça
va tenir compte bah de l'augmentation du
public mais aussi des besoins en
formation des bénévoles il y a par
exemple pour aider les personnes
réfugiées on a mis en place des lieux où
maintenant il va y avoir un accueil avec
des psychologues pour les personnes un
petit peu traumatisées et c'est à
présent la fin de cette édition merci de
nous avoir suivi restez avec nous restez
avec Michel dans quelques instants à
19h30 vous le retrouvez pour le talksh
si on parla sports vendredi vous avez
rendez-vous avec Wilfried Richy pour
l'essentiel de lactu quant à moi je vous
retrouve lundi pour une nouvelle édition
du journal je vous souhaite donc une
très bonne soirée et un excellent
weekend